hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong for a super
special episode that's going to be
harkening back to a former spider-man
and we're also going to be talking about
the current spider-man and we're going
to be doing that with a great guest and
as always jacqueline coley is joining me
jacqueline do you want to talk about how
your team's in the playoffs or do you
just want to talk about how great you
and i both are at wordle the new
sensation that is sweeping
internationally
actually i want to talk about wordle i
don't want to talk about football like i
said supporting the green bay package
right now makes you feel like you need a
shower afterwards but
wordle is the bomb.com thank you for
shouting me out that you joined it i
love that game so much i do like i will
be the last person on it wordle is about
to be by myspace i will be there past
when anybody else thinks it's cool i
don't care i love those i love those
puzzles
five five letters and
it helps mind well see i downloaded an
app that said wordle and so i've just
been playing like world of nonstop and
i'm like how are people tweeting this
why is everybody saying this is the one
wordle and then ash crosston our friend
sent me the actual word that's only once
a day from the uk and so now i'm playing
that one and that's when you get to
tweet but i'm still practicing wordle on
the side a little bit and i don't want
to brag but i have to say this words
with friends i've been playing it
against my mom for years my mom kicks my
ass routinely i beat her four times in a
row i am feeling ah
this is a way for you to level up with
mom this is this is how i get my revenge
with that wake forest university degree
that's gathering dust in the closet his
words with friends we have a friend
joining us today we usually have friends
and we also have a friendly neighborhood
spider-man that we're going to be
talking about it may not be the current
spider-man but we may get to that
spider-man because there's a whole lot
of spider people in the new movie
spider-man no way home that movie will
be spoiled by the way if you listen to
this episode you haven't seen no way
home we're gonna be talking about some
of the plot points in that as we are
with the movie that we're here to
discuss today the amazing spider-man 2
quick refresher that's the one with
andrew garfield and a whole bunch of
villains came out in 2014 directed by
accurately titled mark webb and the
movie 52
on the tomato meter so that is in rotten
territory i like to call it fresh
adjacent jaclyn but it is rotten now it
does have a fresh audience score of 64
so 64 audience 52 tomato meter i want to
give a shout out to a couple fans who
really really really wanted us to do
this episode and that would be edgar
diancio and nicholas bayfield they said
hey talk about amazing spider-man 2 it's
a perfect time to because spider-man no
way home still in theaters and with that
we welcome in the co-creator of the
world girls show you can catch her live
daily on live at the roxy she is a
returning champion to the rotten
tomatoes is wrong show roxy streier have
you ever been more excited to be on the
show talking about a movie than with the
amazing spider-man 2 no
no i've never been this excited that the
text message i received from producer
lucy asking is there any chance you want
to talk about amazing spider-man 2 i
have been waiting
before the movie even came out i feel
like i've been waiting my whole life to
be this excited about anything ever this
is
i was born to do this i'm not even
kidding you guys i just
you well you'll hear you'll find out oh
my gosh yup i'm here i'm ready
all right um do you have an inkling as
to whether rotten tomatoes is right or
wrong about that score 52 percent which
is rotten roxy this is the worst that
the critics have ever done ever in life
rotten tomatoes is so
wrong on this one
i think that
we
are wrong by by we're off by almost 40
points like we are so so wrong on this
one that i think everybody should get
their credit card revoked and you should
have to take some kind of test so that i
know that you are a person able to watch
movies if that's what you think that
this score should be this rewatch was
fantastic for me because back in 2014
jacqueline when i was reviewing this
movie with my schmos noco or christian
harloff i
distinctly remember like in the movie
and giving it a fresh review i think i
gave it like three and a half out of
five schmoes so watching it now
with the lens that i have today i still
don't think it's a terrible movie but i
think that 52
is pretty much right on board i wouldn't
hate it if it limped into fresh
territory like 60
so i might go between the audience
scoring the tomato meter for this so
some quick math that'd be what 58
is what i'll say so it's just just just
short of fresh
in my opinion what say you
uh ready to load up uh everyone
listening i'm gonna load up the hot tape
cannon real quick because this movie is
trash and i haven't said that i think
since the last time roxy's trio was here
but i watched it again and it is a
testament to his acting inability that
andrew garfield has a film like this on
his filmography and is probably gonna
waltz his way into an oscar this year
because oh my god is this bad like it's
embarrassingly bad in dialogue
in
plotting in physics and sense like
believability like there is nothing
about the spider-man that makes sense to
me as a viewer as a lover of spider-man
and as a person
who uses the english language oh my god
is this bad and no it should not be 52
because that would make this movie by
critic and tomato meter standards better
than the eternals which is still an
injustice that that movie is rated as
low it is sunk even lower it is now 47
and you i cannot live in a world i
cannot live in a world
where this movie is rated higher than
that then constantine i knew i didn't
know the constantine was coming i knew
it done i'm done with this movie
it's bad oh this is going to be fun i
love when perducy lucy lets me play
referee between somebody who loves a
movie and somebody who hates a movie and
look but i i also think that my take my
man take on amazing spider-man 2 is a
strong take so we're going to get into
all that we're going to talk about the
movie some behind the scenes stuff and
how some of the characters from amazing
spider-man 2 we maybe have seen recently
and how we felt about that and more
coming up in just a bit but first
jacqueline you get to give us the
synopsis what is amazing spider-man 2
about and how great is rhino yes
jacqueline please tell us all about the
movie the amazing oh my god i'm sorry
roxy this i don't want i don't want the
listeners to get a spin on this because
jacqueline might have a slight tinge of
negativity when giving a synopsis i'm
ready actually i'm not even going to be
negative because i don't want to pain
everyone through it listen peter parker
is back played by andrew garfield his
girlfriend's gwen stacy the most
surprised valedictorian in the history
of valedictorians it's almost like she
didn't know she was the valedictorian
his uh her dad told him last movie stay
away from my daughter he listened to
that for all of no seconds and he's back
to trying to solve the mystery of his
his father's death and we've added every
villain possible we've got electro we've
got green goblin we've got rhino for
reasons beyond sense i think paul
giamani owed mark webb money the only
reason why i could think that he was in
this film but look
harry osborne dies
peter parker is trying to figure out
whether or not he's going to be able to
be spider-man and have a life uh you
know now we have harry osborne taking
the green goblin mantle and all of this
is happening while you know
peter parker's trying to be a
post-high school teen there's a whole
whole bunch of very confusing stuff
having to do with peter parker's
backstory but needless to say it all
results into a
huge uh villain fight towards the end
that results in gwen stacy dying proving
yet once again that peter parker should
have just listened to dennis leary and
stay away from the girl but he didn't
therefore killing her and ending this
franchise thankfully so that we could go
and get tom holland
i
when i left the theater i was on board i
was like give me another one with andrew
garfield let's see what the critics had
to say at the time of the release way
back when we were all in high school in
2014 this is our segment two minutes
with tim courtesy of expert review
curation manager tim ryan take it away
[Music]
superhero movies have to pull off a
tricky balancing act between soaring
adventures and a more down-to-earth
human factor and a lot of critics said
that while andrew garfield and emma
stone gave the amazing spider-man 2 a
beating heart the actual superhero stuff
was a bit too messy and overblown the
amazing spider-man 2 is rotten at 52 on
the tomato meter with 312 reviews and it
has a 64 audience score so what do the
critics have to say in a rotten review
lisa kennedy of the denver post wrote
the trouble with director mark webb's
disappointing sequel is that it wants to
have it both ways to take seriously
human connection and loss and also spin
the spectacular and pulpy
spider-man 2 never locates that sweet
spot however in a fresh review jocelyn
novak of the associated press wrote
garfield is a sensitive actor who brings
a quirky blend of intelligence and
goofiness to peter parker as for stone
she's just so darn charming the rotten
tomatoes critic's consensus reads while
the cast is outstanding and the special
effects are top-notch the latest
installment of the spidey saga suffers
from an unfocused narrative and an
overabundance of characters so that's
the amazing spider-man 2. let's kick it
back to jacqueline and mark wealth and
fame they've ignored podcasting is their
reward back to you folks
oh you are
very accurate as always tim ryan and
before we get into movie talk producie
lucy i want to bring you in here because
i know you're a big spider-man fan how
excited were you to tell roxy the news
that she could come onto the show to do
amazing spider-man 2. that must have
been a fun moment oh i was very excited
i just i i had remembered that she was
on our very first episode spider-man
3 was it
yeah which is still one of our best
performing episodes so when i found out
that she actually loved this movie i was
very giddy i think i squealed
um embarrassingly but yeah no uh it was
perfect i feel like it's a good like
full circle moment for us here today
you know all right let's complete the
circle of love end of life with
movie talk
[Music]
let's get into it i don't know that
anybody would argue this is the best
spider-man movie of all time maybe maybe
roxy will i don't know but this movie
for what it was at the time again 2014
it was coming off of this reboot that
really felt oh very similar to the sam
ramey spiderman and so we're like well
how are we really separating ourselves
and then the sequel comes out and a lot
like spider-man 3 the amazing spider-man
2 just threw so many villains at you
right out of the gate what for my take
this movie does well is not the villain
aspect of it at all i love the
interpersonal relationships i love
seeing peter parker and harry osborn try
to reconnect the relationship between
gwen and peter that was really the
strength of the movie for me um roxy i
think that the emotions in this film get
subterfuge by all the other craziness
happening on screen but i really think
that's crucial to the move and why i
like it so much what about this movie to
you is there like a specific scene you
can point to and say that right there
that's why amazing spider-man 2 is so
underrated yeah i feel like critics say
this very pretentious line about
superhero movies all of the time where
they will say it was a fine movie but
it's not a spider-man movie and it's
like if it has spider-man in it it's a
spider-man movie bro that's a spider-man
movie spider-man's in it it's spider-man
movie so this movie got a lot of heat
for really focusing on the love story
element of it but guess what i'm a lover
of love a shipper of ships if you're
gonna throw me a beautiful love story
with passionate chemistry then that's
what i'm gonna glob on to and it's still
gonna be a spider-man movie because it's
featuring spider-man so there's my
favorite scenes in this movie have to do
with spidey and gwen and one of the best
scenes
is the one where he
web i loves you
over the bridge how are you not going to
just like melt your soul into that she's
going away and he he takes her in his
arms
3 000 miles high i don't know how high a
bridge is it can't be that high 300
feet high however high they are up there
and he says wherever you go i'll go
i love you and we we think in that
moment they're gonna do it they're going
to make this work they're going to be
together
for somehow some way amazing spider-man
3 is going to be in england i don't know
how they're going to pull that off but
like in my soul i knew that's what was
going to take place he says you're my
path you're always going to be my path
i'll follow you there
how do you want more from a movie than
that it's like the most beautiful love
story of all time and it's still a
spider-man love story with gwen stacy
perfect perfect moment perfect scene did
you get my message one message
oh that
was you don't do that i could make it
out i'll tell you what it says i love
you
because i love you
and no offense but you're wrong
you're wrong about us being on different
paths we're not on different paths
you're my path
and you're always gonna be my path
got that scholarship to oxford and she's
going she's going full boris spider-man
gonna follow it now look i will say this
if you go to london really all
spider-man needs to do to be spider-man
is being a city with a lot of tall
buildings so he can do his web shooting
there's big ben there's a tower of
london there's a lot of stuff you can
web off of in london so if if you're
listening to this podcast and you're not
watching it you are missing a show right
now because as roxy's describing this
i'm having a blast watching lucy
literally make a heart with her hands
and watching the amount of eye roll from
jack when i have not seen since i woke
up this morning and maui the wonder dog
gave me the same exact look
jaclyn you don't think this is the
greatest love story of all time no
and spider-man doesn't think it's the
greatest love story of all time gwen
stacy was always a side chick in the way
and the only thing that elevated her was
her death
okay
sorry emma i know that you and andrew
were great and you had amazing chemistry
both on and off screen not trying to dis
on that but
it's just it's the idea that they jammed
this in there you know what this reminds
me of it reminds me of i think the third
x-men movie where it's like okay i see
you guys are trying to set up stuff but
gwen stacy dying the way that storyline
plays out first of all doesn't work as
well when you haven't really introduced
mj so they've already taken away half of
the reason why that storyline worked it
was a weird choice to have her be the
lead interest i think they mostly did
that just to not look like they were
being a complete crash uh cash grab when
they rebooted the series five years
after the first one they wanted to try
and make it different but they really
didn't even give it the it'll start with
the love triangle so she got
shortchanged all the way through let's
let's be honest and keep it real and ah
yeah it's not the greatest love story
everybody was sitting there being like
but where's mj no
it's it's funny because i wasn't
wondering where mj was and i did take
that casting of emma stone is playing
gwen stacy as opposed to kirsten dunst
playing mary jane the love interest in
the sam raimi spider-man movies i kind
of looked at that as just like the
studio being hey we need to separate
ourselves we know it's a different
spider-man we're gonna have some
different villains but we need to put
somebody else in let's do the gwen stacy
angle instead of the mary jane angle now
if you look at amazing spider-man 2 a
lot of the headlines are jamie foxx's
electro and paul giamatti is rhino and
dane dahan is the goblin but
my favorite part and and i'll give roxy
credit on this rewatching it this week
were those just quiet intimate funny
young love moments between gwen and
peter and the one it's not like the i
love you in webs it's not when they're
at graduation and he sees her dead dad
staring daggers at him who's reminding
him hey i told you get away from my
daughter it is
there's a moment where gwen is being
chased by security at the at the at
oscar and she's she's running around and
she's trying to um uh
get away from these people who are on to
her because now she's on to
what is happening at the building so
she has to hide in a closet and who
shows up to help her into the closet
it's peter and they've already broken up
but now they're not really broken up so
it's a will they won't they kind of
thing and it's just such a fun romantic
comedy kind of moment that that i really
enjoyed watching their interplay and
their chemistry is the highlight of this
movie for me it has nothing to do with
the v and i love me some jamie foxx it
has nothing to do with any of the
villains it has nothing to do with any
of that stuff this is the maintenance
closet gwen
this is the most cliched hiding place
you could have chosen this is the
stupidest hiding place take us to the
bahamas hiding place listen i gotta talk
to you about england i guess because
and so maybe that is more towards
jacqueline's side where like i came to
see a spider-man movie and the best part
of it was this like you've got male
relationship between gwen and peter that
was the best part of the movie for me
spider-man can't be happy he can't fall
in like he can't live his life
believably yes he can't have a meet cute
he can't have these moments where he's
in the closet with his girl and they and
they were and they won't and and they
roxy together
every every romantic comedy has taught
this from the wedding planner to the
latest romantic comedy to hit netflix
you gotta have a triangle there has to
be the dynamic by deleting mj mary jane
watson by taking her out of that they
completely ruined the actual part of it
the only real you would say
tension between these two is the fact
that he's spider-man and her dad said to
keep away and because both of those
things are roundly ignored throughout
most of the narrative it removes it
this movie is bad and doesn't know where
it's going because it doesn't know where
it's going and this is evident by all of
the dangling plot holes like the opening
of the movie with the parents
where was that going and then then
andrew garfield standing in front of his
like charlie day with the like red
strings like here's my family's picture
and i'm gonna figure it out and then we
just ignore that for the rest of this
rest of the movie that just stopped the
movie
i guarantee you that mark webb could
write a josh tranq style tweet talking
about there's a beautiful spider-man
movie that we wanted to make and that's
not what you get in theaters
but
what we got is a jumbled up mess like
just tie together the plot outside of
gwen
and peter
and you know that this movie didn't know
or care where it was going let me ask
you this roxy do you i don't find there
to be a single hole do you feel like
this movie is short changed by not
having a sequel do you feel like they
were trying to set some stuff up in this
movie that they just didn't get a chance
to capitalize on where it's like oh well
we would have made that we would have
answered that question in the third one
but we never got there it can't be a
feeling mark that has to be a fact right
there's no way they've talked about this
that there definitely was gonna be a
third movie we set up for a third movie
we clearly are hinting at sinister six
there's a lot of plans that they had for
the future that we never got to get to
but even with all of that this was a
full complete movie when you think about
the fact that there there isn't this
love triangle which by the way really
toxic trope that i would love for us to
steer away from in rom-coms but in this
movie there is a love triangle element
and it is the fact that they can't be
together because it is too dangerous for
her and guess what his worst nightmare
comes through it was too dangerous for
her she dies and the fact that this will
this movie was willing to go there
unlike any other spider-man movie yes
we've had some extreme losses in
spider-man movies but this being the
biggest one the love of your life is
dead
the movie said
listen we're going to set up a scenario
and we're going to say they can't be
together because if they are something
really bad is going to happen and then
they ignore that they can't be together
and something really bad happens that's
follow through that's not a loose end
that's a tied bow i'll give you that i
will give you that all day because
that's my other favorite scene and it's
morbid and i'm sorry but it is so well
done is the death scene i'm not rooting
for gwen to eat it i want gwen to to
live and go to london and have a great
career but the the fight scene in
question where
we have spider-man and he's battling bad
guys and then gwen falls and she's
falling and we've seen this a thousand
times where spider-man is gonna swing
his web and he's gonna save her just in
the nick of time and it's gonna feel
like a nice easy bungee jump down to the
surface but he just doesn't quite get
there in time and it's the sound kids i
can still hear it in my head it's the
sound of the skull
hitting the concrete and you're just
like ooh
ooh she is at least going to be in the
concussion protocol and it turns out
they had to carter off the field jaclyn
because she was dead that didn't do
anything to you emotionally were you
already checked out by that time i did
it absolutely did something for
emotionally i'm not trying to say that
it isn't
that's a pf chang's dinner but we could
have had no boobs
because i'll say this again for my
witcher episode it's not bad it's an
outback steakhouse but we could have had
you know the nicest steakhouse in town
you know what i mean like del frisco's
styling like we we missed it because
this is the let's think about it this
way here's the what if which is what
they were setting up imagine peter does
walk away and he tries to date mary jane
watson and he tries to leave gwen alone
but even though he tries to leave her
alone because she's still in his parents
periphery parental world she still dies
and he realizes that
anybody that he is close to in any way
whether it be he tried to do the right
thing and she still died
that real separation like if he really
like let her go because let's be honest
he never let her go throughout the movie
and actually did try to move on and then
gets devastated and then it kills his
idea of ever wanting to be with mary
jane that's the way you want to start a
third spider-man then we get a whole
skyfall type spider-man
i'll give you that because roxy you
gotta admit peter does not do a good job
of actually staying away from gwen at
all like he's like he's like me when i
order pizza and i'm by myself and i have
like a couple slices of pizza and i'm
like all right i'm done i'm done or it's
like the pie that jaclyn made for me for
christmas which is gone by the way now
and i had two slices of pie the first
night i got it and then i was like all
right i'm putting it away and then i
kept going back to the pie and i could
not resist going back to the pie peter
parker could have done a better job of
actually letting glenn stacy be and it
feels like glenn gwen was going to be
doing just fine i think that peter kind
of
the guy's responsible for her death but
is that kind of an appeal to you roxy
that now it's this darker superhero that
has all of this this this track record
of sadness and gloom around him i think
in the words of my girl gwen mark nobody
makes my decisions for me and that's the
stronger choice in this movie i am so
sick of watching lois lane
over and over and over again yeah
superman gotta come save her no there
she is in the water aquaman's gotta come
help her nope lois just can't do
anything just woe is me lois lane
and i have a lot of love for lois but i
don't want to see her again and i don't
want to watch gwen b lois i want to
watch her to say things like nobody
makes decisions for me i make my own
decisions i'm a grown woman and she
chooses to come back he's he
webs her hand to a car and she says no
i'm going to fight through this i'm
going to be here we're a team that's not
him deciding anything for her yes he
wants to be with her and he's deciding
for himself that that's his choice but
then as a grown adult she's saying my
choice is to be with you
that's what that's what a mature love is
that's what it should be we shouldn't be
watching these superhero movies and
rooting for these love stories where the
superhero gets to decide we're together
or we're not together because they have
powers isn't a relationship based on two
people making a consensual choice
together i think it is two people making
a consensual choice together i'm not
trying to say that that is it but let's
be honest he never really makes a choice
he's just one foot in one foot out the
whole movie he speaks oh i love you
we're together and we're a team and then
the whole time he's conflicted about the
promise that he made to his to her dad
and all this other kind of stuff just
please grasp this though i i i get what
you're saying
the but we haven't talked about any of
the other stuff like how does electro
become a villain like y'all just want to
focus on emma and andrew garfield and i
get it they're the shiny toy and they
work and they're awesome in this movie
but the best they are it's still lesser
than what it could been and it does not
like take away the stench of all of the
crap that is around them what does
electro have like just give me that so
electro electro is such a conundrum for
me because again i love jamie foxx one
of my favorite actors of all time going
all the way back to a living color i was
so excited when he was cast in this role
and electro is such a cool looking
character and it's a very interesting
power and it's one of those things where
he's got a very edward enigma kind of
angle where it's like you're this genius
and you're sort of reclusive and you're
not really good with the other humans
but now we give you all this power and
you're suddenly manifesting all of it in
this very dark and dangerous way and
those are the scenes roxy for me that
just didn't really pay off the way i
wanted it to and i will give uh
christian harloff all due credit he's
the one that pointed out to me when we
were reviewing this movie how
ridiculously stupid every
extra is in this movie because when
there's a massive fight scene between an
electrified villain and spider-man
they're all just standing behind a
barricade like 10 feet away just like oh
this will be a fun fight to watch it's
like no you're in danger run as fast as
you can the other way what villains
worked the best for you roxy streier
so i want to preface this by letting you
guys know that my favorite part of the
prequels is hayden christensen and i
don't say that to
to
for a shock factor i say that because
for years and years after watching this
movie i have been confused with what you
guys are all seeing i feel like i live
in a different planet i live in a planet
where dan dahan is so talented yeah and
and his goblin is so good i live in a
world where electro works
fabulously so i don't get what you guys
are seeing i live in a world where i
feel so lucky that we had rhino in this
movie as like just an extra little t
there was no there was no part of the
rhino storyline that everybody freaked
out why is rhino even then this how
about we say thank you so much rhino
thank you so much paul for dropping by
what a fun little nugget that was it's
bizarre to me that people say this movie
was fully loaded with villains and it
didn't work but then we love no way home
fully loaded with your friends okay
what are we talking about we knew why
they were there
and they all made sense to be there they
literally said hey this is the premise
of too many villains in the movie
this was too many villains and harry met
sally and the mystery solving of the
parents and a little like you know
corporate science espionage just for
good measure and the prodigal son like
just how many stories are you going to
put in here look i get it roxy but like
let me just say i don't want to be too
rough on this because i know some people
love this movie and i do love that that
andrew garfield has gotten the
redemption because i agree with you and
mark 100
the one thing the amazing spider-man
series gets correct is casting i do not
disagree with a single casting going
back to dennis leary in the first one
and paul
uh i forget who played lizard in the
first one but
everybody who is cast is great they just
didn't give them any kind of a coherent
plot to portray these characters like it
just paul giamani as rhino was funny
but like the idea that it was necessary
is just i'm sorry
roxy i i will say this i think you have
mom goggles when it comes to this movie
and all spider-man movies to a certain
degree you know how like lucille backed
me up on this as a mom it's your little
you everything they do is precious and
gorgeous and you will never see them
anything less than the most
amazing talented person
on the planet don't let anybody tell you
any different unless it's about one of
your other children who are equally as
great that's what moms are supposed to
do
roxy you have mong goggles on this movie
because girl there are problems i i hear
you and while i might have mom goggles i
want to keep them on because i want to
live in a world in which electro
storyline breaks my heart watching
somebody who wants to be seen that is
his whole goal he's dying to be seen and
he gets that across and when we have
that elevator ride with him and gwen and
she remembers his name and that to him
is the biggest thing in the world i'm
sold on this character i get the whole
thing when his face is being plastered
on all the billboards and he's realizing
he's making a mess of things but he
can't help himself because his whole
life he has just been in the shadows and
nobody's noticed him when when
spider-man his idol doesn't remember who
he is after saying to him i need your
help come on like this this is one of
the great spider-man villains that rips
me to shreds to watch him go through
this because they genuinely built up his
story they spend time with him saying
here's why you should care about him
because he's all of us he's all of us
who have felt left out on the playground
or like we weren't noticed or picked on
or not seen who had a little bit of hope
left but then on our worst day that hope
turns to trash
this was such a moving storyline that
people for some reason have have
forgotten about or say things like it
was just one of the villains and it was
so not well done and he looked so stupid
and what was with the gap in his teeth
what are you guys paying attention to
i'm thinking about this this poor guy
this poor guy and it was his birthday oh
it it does break my heart to a certain
extent and i think the the look of
electro is awesome and i think that
that's one of the reasons why
fans who even if you weren't necessarily
as big of a fan of this movie as roxy is
i think that there were so many people
that were looking forward to the
possible return of some of these
characters in spider-man no way home and
so like i said we are going to talk
about that movie in depth a little bit
too so i hope everybody listening has
seen it roxy i love the point you made
about why are people
crapping on amazing spider-man 2 having
too many villains but not no way home
because i do think that there's a lot of
folks out there that were watching
spider-man no way home with jaclyn's mom
goggles because i don't think that's a
perfect movie i have a lot of problems
i'm a one-universe guy i'm not a
multiverse i can have fun with an into
the spider verse it's animated it feels
fun it feels light this i it felt like
the multiverse to me feels like an
excuse to get a lot of just former
villains and highlights of previous
spider-man movies into a movie together
having said that i had a lot of fun with
it and i will say it was great seeing
jamie foxx again it was great seeing
lizard again reece siphons it was great
seeing andrew garfield who i think
there's an argument to be made is the
best spider-man of them all so
jacqueline i'll start with you then i'll
pivot back to roxy what were the parts
of no way home that reference amazing
spider-man 2 that worked for you if
there were any i think the best and this
is maybe a little bit on the nose was
when
toby turns to
andrew and says you're a good spider-man
like i've seen
like you're an amazing spider-man you're
an amazing spider yeah there you go
thank you i don't want to screw up the
line
i think
i've seen a few movies now between
ghostbusters and amazing spiderman no
way home and the new screen movie not to
give anything away
where the writers are very plainly
voicing the feelings of audiences in
clever meta sometimes very matrix is
another example of this where they are
literally just putting the audience
they're just taking reddit boards and
putting it in a script and for the most
part i have very little patience for it
but that moment did not feel as cheesy
and as forced as i think it could have
been
if it was handled by lesser actors in a
lesser stakes moment and so as stupid as
that was it really made me
i liked that a lot and i really liked
when both
toby and andrew but particularly andrew
because he lost the most
told tom hollands peter parker
listen
we've been through the bad side of this
and
you're going to learn lessons that we
had to learn the hard way if you don't
learn them on your own the easier way
and i really loved those big brother
moments uh and anytime they put andrew
garfield in the lab coat that was great
yeah roxy i i was late to see in this
movie and so i i was pretty good at
avoiding spoilers and i appreciate
people like you who saw the movie early
on and didn't give anything away didn't
ruin anything but the the theme that i
saw through a lot of twitter was how
surprisingly emotional this movie was
and so in my head i'm thinking oh well
this is probably just some nice moments
between peter and mj but no it was
between peter and the other peter and
the other peter and watching those three
i mean i thought that that garfield and
maguire might come in and make a cameo
and then the rest would just be them
voice over doing spider-man stunts but
no they're like in the movie they're
like actors in the movie how rewarding
as a lifelong spider-man fan was that
for you to see incredible i thought the
same as you mark i thought that they
were gonna pop in it was gonna be a
really cute moment the audience was
gonna cheer and they were gonna leave
but they are in a full act an act in a
half of this movie
this is like
a dream of mine and of a lot of
spider-man fans and i don't say that
this movie was fully loaded to to crap
on it i loved spider-man no way home i
just think that it's unfair that this
gets so much love and some of the other
movies don't but for me going back to
the moments that really worked that
referenced amazing spider-man 2 when
when finally andrew garfield when his
peter catches mj yes
come on i mean if you haven't been
waiting for that moment especially after
talking about what you just talked about
mark that sound that's ingrained in our
heads of her skull cracking on the
ground and her body going limp and when
he catches mj we feel that redemption we
feel that moment of oh my gosh this is
what he's needed to move forward it's
really cool and the other moment that
really got me is when he says peter 3
because i've felt like that since i've
seen this movie he is he's always the
third when people are like what's the
best spider-man movies and they're like
well the rainy ones are the best don't
know i love the tom holland ones listen
i love every spider-man movie that's
ever existed i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
say anything bad about spider-man movie
but peter three there he is again pier
three and you just feel for andrew
garfield who is a beautiful actor a
brilliant performer who is always touted
as peter
i
cr i closed my eyes when mj was falling
and garfield went and garfield's spread
went to go catch her because i'm like i
just if i hear the sound effect i'm
leaving the theater i closed my eyes and
so i didn't and i didn't hear anything
like that and i opened my eyes i was
like oh good she survived it was a nice
redemption moment i will agree with you
there i i wanted
with the villains in no way home i still
felt a little bit like the villains in
amazing spider-man 2 where i think it
would have been cooler to focus on one
or the other because there was at roxy's
you said there's so much there with max
and becoming electro in that storyline
that's that's its own movie there's so
much with the relationship between harry
and peter that could be its own movie
and then we have angry paul gmail who
again i can't stress this enough rhino
is like he might be the most angry
character i've ever seen in any movie
ever he is so upset particularly when
he's behind the wheel of a huge truck
but it was the same thing in no way home
where once again jamie foxx is back and
he's great as electro but
i i didn't get to sink my teeth into
that character at all and so i was a
little bummed about that like i i get
it's a multiverse we're opening up and
everybody's there for a quick hello and
goodbye but i wanted to see more i still
don't feel like electro's gotten the
justice that that he deserves if that
makes sense it was nice when he kind of
just looked like normal jamie foxx
though and there's the one line like oh
you your looks changed i think that was
just a nice little moment for the
audience who has been ripping apart the
teeth and the hair for so long i was
glad for jamie foxx that he got to be
electro looking like jamie foxx for one
minute so even if it was just that
because i agree with you mark i would
like an even more fleshed out version of
him but even for just that moment where
he gets to be like see i'm just a normal
i'm just a villain man can you stop
making fun of the teeth
that wasn't my call i'm just here just
let me let me do my villainy thing
good enough for me
uh last take on amazing spider-man 2
before we move on to some behind the
scenes stuff and in that
behind-the-scenes talk i am going to ask
y'all who your favorite spider-man of
all time is just be prepared for that um
any other scenes that we need to get to
in your estimation jacqueline coley
i think that's good
for the scenes on the amazing spider-man
other than you know why is ant-man nurse
do we ever answer that too like there's
just so many what like there's just
because she's gotta put him through
school
she's gotta pull she got paid because
sally fields is an oscar-winning actress
and they needed to give her more to do
god you talk about i mean that's cool i
know i know we debate the best
spider-man of all time there's really
some good arguments to who's the best
aunt may of all time because they're all
great they are all
fantastic
more on that in just a sec as we
transition to behind the scenes
[Music]
at the time i don't know if it still
holds this record i imagine it's got an
outside shot of doing it this was the
largest production
ever to shoot in new york city which is
saying something and when you watch the
movie i mean you see all these elaborate
setups of times square and it's a great
new york feeling movie i think something
like it's like 3 500 extras or something
like that total and again a lot of those
extras actually complete morons in the
actual movie
kids if you're listening to this show
and you see two superheroes super
villains fighting each other in the
street do not watch do not get your cell
phone out and run the other way because
there's going to be a lot of collateral
damage i cannot stress that enough now
we also have rumors that now we have all
these villains back are we gonna get a
sinister six movie what's the spin-off
movie roxy what would be the next
iteration of a spider-man movie or like
a spin-off spider-man character movie
that you really want to see is it
another venom i know you're a fan of
that franchise as well do you want to
see
do you want to see gwen stacy get her
own backstory what do you want to see
next out of a spider-man flick oh
gosh all of that sounds good but like
most people i
i'm in the camp that it's definitely
time for uh miles morales live action
movie that would be so freaking fun and
there's so many mentors that he could
have now if we want to bring peter into
that universe there's just so many of
them there's this amazing moment in
amazing spider-man 2 actually where
there's a little spider-man that comes
out right and i was just thinking how
cool would that have been if when he
takes off his mask he's like a little
miles morales and then later on we bring
him back and but but that's not what
ended up happening there but some kind
of a mentor mentee
movie between the two spideys would be
uh incredible okay jack when you buying
a ticket to that movie uh yes definitely
um i'm definitely buying a ticket to it
i was just thinking a little bit more
about sony
what's really interesting about this
movie i'm a little bit scared so like
instant spider-verse was great i want to
see what they do with the next one
but
sony before kevin feige got on board
with this very last effort are not the
greatest on landing the planes sometimes
so i really worry
is that a shot at spider-man's parents
there you go that's funny in this
version yes
um but i just i'm a little bit worried
like um it seems like they're gonna keep
making movies together but miles morales
is not part of the mcu and let's be
honest outside of
sam raimi where they couldn't land the
plane an amazing spider-man where they
couldn't land the plane
are we going to call venom landing the
plane like i don't know
basically i'm saying i'm looking forward
to miles morales if it's in the right
hands if it's in the right hands so we
we have these
and really the next movie we're getting
in in any spider-man lineage would be
that morbius movie with jared leto i saw
the trailer for that when i saw
spiderman no way home
i'm in man i am in on that i do not know
why but i love the look i love the
empirical aspect of morbius is the
character i think jared leto the one
thing you can't say
you know he's going to literally sink
his teeth into this roll the hint that
we get a vulture maybe that becomes
sinister six i'm excited for more of
this you can call me crazy i think it's
going to be awesome anybody with me i'm
with you on that also i love how
morbia's probably happened because of
how angry jared leto and jared leto's
agents were about joaquin phoenix
winning an oscar for the joker that is
absolutely like he's like you think you
can do superheroes better than i can sir
that is an absolute whole my beer moment
you are completely right about that
the trailer did get me very excited but
what i'm really hoping because now this
has been pushed to april fool's day for
its release i really hope that this
movie doesn't exist that this has been
like the big joke that they are about to
play on all of us that for years has
been getting pushed back and we've seen
footage and you get to the theater and
it just says april fool's please
please do that instead
i mean
so much fun to just watch social media
burn that day it would be so great to be
like hey hey you're going to see more
videos no spoilers and then everybody
goes to see it and it's just like dinner
see you later
yes
i mean it's such a bad thing to do but
honestly i'd be excited to see it as
well we do have a debate that is age-old
that is not necessarily going to be
settled here today but everybody always
wants to know i even got to do a versus
episode on this who is the best
spider-man and as it happens with most
of my versus episodes i really enjoyed
writing it i enjoyed performing it i
cannot remember who i picked is it toby
mcguire is it andrew garfield or is it
tom holland who is the best spider-man
live-action of them all um
if you want to go miles morales with uh
into the spider-verse
totally co-sign that that's my favorite
spider-man movie of all time but my
favorite spider-man
man andrew garfield's up there and it's
not just because he's so good as peter
parker spider-man it's because of how
much he loves the character when he was
at comic-con one year he dressed up as
spider-man and nobody knew it was him
and then he took it then he took the
mask off and it was andrew garfield that
was such a cool comic-con hall h moment
roxy stryer who is the best spider-man
of them all is it
our guy andrew garfield the all three of
the main live-action spider-man have
been amazing so no no knock on any of
them
but when i think of the best live-action
spider-man
if if i'm including peter parker in that
so like you're the best at the whole
role i think the one who is the best at
the at the the duality of both peter
parker and spider-man is andrew garfield
the duality spider-man goes to andrew
garfield how about jack mccoley okay so
the best spider-man ever is spider pig
voiced by john delaney
with a
very close runner-up for spider-pig noir
which is voiced by nicholas cage those
two are the best spider people period
yeah start with you
toby mcguire
had
the best
spider-man
at the box office meaning he made
spider-man a movie event
andrew garfield is the best actor we've
ever had play spider-man and so
therefore played him the best on screen
and peter parker
is the best spider-man that had stories
that supported him
wait wait you mean tom holland tom
holland parker yeah i said peter parker
tom holland has the best spider-man i
know in it he is he's not any character
but he's had the best story
he had the best performance
and then for had the best like sort of
box office movie
so
for whatever it is in a certain respect
tom holland got stacked up really well
and then pulled it off andrew garfield
made they made lemonades out at a lemon
um and it would be so interesting to see
if one they could have cast him just a
couple years earlier
and if he would have been able to have
the mcu type run that tom holland did
just like what's
amazing things could be a part of it not
that i don't want tom holland there but
who's the best who do you think's the
best
i don't think it's equal to say because
yeah okay in a certain respect tom
holland had a better spider-man run
altogether all through it but he also
got the benefit of stacking on top of it
10 years of mcu cheater cheater lemonade
literally how are you going to judge
that like that's the other reason why i
think that was between toby and andrew
oh really
that's not true they say tom
no
it's it's it's the three of them are
hard to judge because they're on
separate things it's the thing you
talked about spider-man no way home why
do people not feel like that one is
overfilled because they got to do a
shortcut through the mcu and they got to
take all of that mcu and the same rabies
spiderman's knowledge they actually were
able to put them together in a big
mountain of poop and he just stood on
top of it yeah i mean look again i
really like no way home but i i can't
stand superheroes being morons
especially doctor strange and spider-man
fighting each other and then spider-man
leaving dr strange in some weird
multiverse hung up with this guy's a
superhero this guy helps save the
universe with you okay and aunt may are
you kidding me with everybody's get a
second chance these are horrible human
beings that you're trying to save and
we're saving five people despite
thousands of cops and innocent
bystanders in this world who just died
but we don't care about them anyway
that's a whole different subject for
another day um this has been such a fun
episode and it's been so enjoyable to
have jaclyn who maybe isn't the biggest
amazing spider-man 2 fan and roxy who is
a huge supporter of it i love these kind
of conversations because it proves we
can all be civil with each other even as
we disagree about something as vitally
important as spider-man movies roxy
thank you so much i know you have a huge
year coming up i am so excited to enjoy
it with you what are you most excited
about for 2022 and where can all the
kids out there find you the whirl girls
it's all my mug the world girls is the
thing i'm most excited about we're live
every wednesday and sunday youtube.com
the world girls at the world girls roxy
do you have a movie or tv recommendation
i guess port charles can kind of count
if you if you just want to make port
charles your official recommendation to
close the show album it's really good
but i i think the show that i really
wowed me is the final season of search
party y'all know about search party i've
heard about it i have no idea what it is
all right i'm a wrestler development
anything that maybe is in that's oh me
too and yeah so so true so same but
search party is a show that is now on
hbo max it had a whole weird journey to
get there but it is in its fifth season
and it it changed genres every season it
was like a murder mystery show and now
it's turned into an apocalypse show and
i can't believe that this is how they
did it but it's a really great look into
millennial culture and the downfalls of
millennial culture and it's hysterical
and dark and i can't recommend it enough
search party and now it's all out so you
can binge the whole thing i know we like
to do that here binge it away search
party and i will give a shout out to
port charles one more time once again
you can email us anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com however you're
listing this podcast we appreciate it
subscribe rate review whatever that app
likes you to do go ahead and do that
because it just makes jacqueline i feel
all warm and cozy so for everyone here
at rotten tomatoes is wrong our
incredible engineer brian perez producer
lucy our very special guest roxy streier
good luck with your patriots in the
playoffs jacqueline good luck with your
packers in the playoffs and as for me
i'm merely mark ellis and my team gets a
new nickname february 2nd will it be the
groundhogs will we see our shadow all
that and more next time on rye tomatoes
is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you